the single biggest theme to pay
attention to right now in investing is
the federal reserve their monetary
policy and its impact on inflation we go
all the way back to 2020 we know that
the federal reserve pursued a very loose
monetary policy in response to the covet
impact that loose monetary policy drove
an asset bubble across all asset classes
and also we saw consumer prices explode
upwards that led to the 8.6
inflation that we have today it's a
40-year high it's mainly driven by that
loose monetary policy there was also
fiscal policy implemented by elected
officials there's supply chain
disruptions and a number of other things
that fed into it but loose monetary
policy was the main driver in my opinion
now going back about eight months the
federal reserve started to talk tough
they started to talk about the fact that
they were going to raise interest rates
and potentially conduct quantitative
tightening asset prices have started to
fall but inflation has been persistent
that's why we are at that 40-year high
today
recently on the all-in podcast chamath
palopita was talking about inflation cpi
being quite sticky around eight or nine
percent and why the federal reserve not
only are they not going to give up in
the short term in his opinion but it's
actually more likely that they're going
to over correct that they're going to
tighten so much that things will start
to break other assets that seem to be
unaffected today likely will feel the
impact of the federal reserve's
decisions here's chamas comments on the
all in podcast
i think you need to buckle your seat
belt because the next three four five
months of cpi
will probably be very very bad seven
eight nine percent why
there are a handful of components that
have gotten completely run away number
one the biggest one is rent and so rent
works on a three-month lag we're going
to reintroduce what the true
owner's equivalent rent is into cpi so
we can already forecast that cpi going
up oil is at 105 bucks a barrel russia
is basically trying to break the back of
europe by now messing with their nat gas
supplies um the german energy minister
yesterday said that if that happens it
could be a contagion equivalent to
lehman brothers with respect to energy
when you play all of these things out
what you have is unfortunately
rampant runaway costs that really have
no mechanism to get back in check
in the absence of some real governmental
changes our policy on this ukraine
russia war you know how we intend to
sort of uh work or cooperate or fight
with china all of these things have to
get solved so in the absence of that
prices are going to continue to go up
and so what does the fed do
how does it throw away what little
credibility it has left when there's
eight and nine percent inflation prints
and saying we think we're done for right
now you can't do that so they will over
correct because there is just going to
be so much
pressure for them to act all roads
i think lead to lower equity prices and
i think what david said astutely is
we've seen the first wave but now it has
to touch all these other areas now one
of the interesting things about the
federal reserve and their impact on
financial markets is that historically
they actually aren't worth paying
attention to what do i mean if you ask
somebody like peter lynch the famous
investor who beat the market for decades
he used to always say if you spent 16
minutes worrying about the macro economy
that's 14 minutes too long and just
focus on buying great companies focus on
just buying the businesses that will end
up generating more cash flow in the
future the problem is while there is
some truth to not paying attention to
the macro economy that the fed is in
control in the moment we don't have free
markets and the federal reserve has
created one big trait either you go with
the fed or you try to fight them and as
the old adage says don't fight the fed
the federal reserve conducting this
quantitative tightening and increasing
interest rates has created a correlation
closer and closer to one across all
assets historically the 6040 global
portfolio of stocks and bonds if stocks
go down bonds go up and vice versa but
instead what we've seen year to date in
2022 is that all assets are falling
stocks bonds currencies commodities real
estate bitcoin crypto and everything
else
as you see all assets falling together
it signals that we're in somewhat of a
liquidity crisis maybe shorter maybe
more drawn out nobody knows but at the
end of the day when all assets are
correlating towards one which you have
to ask yourself so what's the fed going
to do and until the fed reverses course
it's very unlikely that asset prices
will recover and the fed is only going
to reverse course if they cause so much
pain so much economic damage they were
sitting in a recession and people are
waving the white flag saying please give
up please give up
because until then the federal reserve's
just looking at that inflation number
and with it sitting at 8.6 percent in
may it's a big big problem and so
they're going to do everything they
possibly can go into their toolbox of
interest rates and quantitative
tightening and say we got to get
inflation under control this is the big
battle inflation versus the federal
reserve who will blink first we're going
to find out over the next six months or
so